- Two of the greatest thespians
of all-time are back together in the new
Martin Scorsese film, "The Irishman."
Robert De Niro and Al Pacino.
But today, it's not a team-up,
it's an all-out battle royale to see
who has had the most impressive career,
and all week, the trash talk
between these two has been hot.
See?
They both really wanna win this,
and I'm excited to be here
because I even dressed
like I'm in "The Irishman."
Pacino, De Niro, neither one's Irish.
Oh well.
- Ha!
- Here's how I'll determine my winner.
Round number one: box office.
Round two: Tomatometer.
Round three: most iconic.
Then we'll do a wild card round
after which you, the audience,
will have the final say.
So without further ado, let's kick off
what could be the most hotly debated
episode in the history of this show.
It's the dude from "Mad Dog and Glory"
versus the guy in "Gigli."
Let's get it on.
- Brother, you are going down.
- Your move, Dolly Parton.
- Round one: box office.
(bell dinging)
Both of these legendary actors
have been in the talkies
for decades, but don't worry.
We adjusted the box office for inflation,
so the money's fair, but what's not?
De Niro's been in so many
more movies than Pacino.
Bobby D has made 77 films
that we have data for.
Al, just 37!
So predictably, De Niro's
combined total movie receipts
are stacked higher than Pacino's.
So this should be an easy
round win for Robert, right?
- What kind of a show are you
guys puttin' on here today?
- Nah, ah, ah, not so fast.
Despite trailing De Niro by 40
theatrically released films,
Pacino's competitive in both domestic
and worldwide box office totals.
Robert can claim the hefty
$5.2 billion in the States,
and $9.9 billion worldwide.
Al currently stands at
$4.2 billion domestic
and $7.5 billion overall,
and Pacino's average film gross
is actually well above his counterpart,
over $200 million per flick
while De Niro is just $130 million.
As you can imagine, they both
have had their share of hits.
Robert De Niro's highest
grossing film of all-time?
Well it just happened, "Joker."
It crossed a billion bucks.
As for Al Pacino?
He made this little movie a long time ago,
maybe you've heard of it, "The Godfather."
- Bada beep, bada bap,
bada boop, bada beep.
- $1.5 billion, and that friends,
will buy you a lot of new bedsheets.
So, the horse joke, I hope
they put that clip in.
(man screaming)
He's got the better average
and is in more "Godfather" movies,
so Al Pacino is gonna
win round number one.
- Yabba dabba doo.
- Round two: Tomatometer.
(bell dinging)
Robert and Al.
I feel so bad calling them that.
It's like if they were here,
I couldn't even look them in the eye.
I'd just get nervous
and stand in the corner,
like Blair Witch-y.
- Aw, what are you, some
kind of chicken ship?
- Bob and A-Slice, as
two giants of cinema,
have made a ton of films
that are super high
on the Tomatometer.
However, their averages, eh, not so much.
Only one fella can claim a fresh average.
That's Al Pacino at 61.9%.
Robert De Niro gets close at 56.4%.
But again, De Niro's
made like 40 more movies,
so there's bound to be
some stinkers in there.
Hold your nose as we run through the duds.
De Niro's "The Gang That
Couldn't Shoot Straight" is 0%.
Wow, no one liked it.
But, to be fair, it only had
like five critic reviews.
"Godsend" is at 4%, as is
"The Bridge of San Luis Rey."
If those films don't ring
a bell, I know what will.
"Jack and Jill."
Ugh.
- Al Pacino, the movie actor?
- Yes, yes, stay calm.
- Pacino makes an extended appearance
in that all-time pile of junk,
and it's his Tomatometer low point at 3%.
Who is the 3% that liked "Jack and Jill"?
Who walked out of that movie like,
"I had a really good time"?
(speaking in foreign language)
Okay, let's get that stink
off us with this list
of the gentleman's most celebrated
cinematic accomplishments.
Robert De Niro checks in with
a pair of 98% fresh classics,
like "Taxi Driver" and "Brazil."
Al Pacino also has a 98% on his resume.
That thing, "The Godfather."
Okay, again, who is the 2%
that did not like "The Godfather"?
It's got to be the same folk
that liked "Jack and Jill," right?
- It's not personal, Sonny,
it's strictly business.
- If you combine all their movies
and do a top 10, according
to the Tomatometer,
De Niro can boast eight of those films,
including "A Bronx
Tale," which he directed.
Pacino has three,
and if that math doesn't
check out for you,
it's because they were
both in "The Godfather II,"
which is a pretty sweet 97%.
More movies, more in the top 10,
and much less "Jack and Jill."
That means the win in round number two
goes to Mr. De Niro.
(bell dinging)
- What's up now, brah?
- Yeah, what's up now, brah?
- Round three: most iconic.
(bell dinging)
This is where even me, Mark Joyous Ellis
will admit my competitive
nature gets the best of me.
I mean, who's more iconic?
They're Pacino and De Niro.
Who doesn't do the Travis Bickle line?
- You talkin' to me?
- Who's never won a court case
and immediately bellowed "Hooah"?
- Hooah!
(crowd cheering)
- So let's take a look at
their most iconic roles,
to see who maybe has a slight edge.
Al Pacino kicks off with Michael Corleone.
We know him, we love him,
he's into some seedy stuff.
- Just when I thought I was out.
They pull me back in.
- Then he had Tony Montana,
also into seedy stuff, "Serpico."
By the way, Al Pacino
got so into character
while making "Serpico,"
he tried to make a
citizen's arrest on someone.
I can't even commandeer
a Ford Focus from my mom.
- That's a joke.
- Let's toss in Sonny
from "Dog Day Afternoon,"
Tony D'Amato in "Any Given Sunday,"
and his Oscar-winning turn as
Frank in "Scent of a Woman."
Is that kind of a sneaky, creepy title?
"Scent of a Woman," I
know the guy's blind,
but "Hi, I'm Frank. I go
around smelling women."
It's a little off putting to me, anyway.
- Intelligence, of which you have none.
- So, what iconic
portrayals from Team De Niro
can match the Pacino Squad?
How about Vito Corleone
from "Godfather II"?
Sir Travis Bickle, Jake
LaMotta from "Raging Bull,"
Jimmy Conway from "Goodfellas," Al Capone?
So, the only way to break
this most iconic deadlock
is to focus on the one film that sees them
square off against each other.
The movie that stars both Robert and Al.
If you're at home and you
said, "Righteous Kill,"
then I want you to pause
this vid, go outside,
take a walk around the block,
then come on back inside when you're ready
to be an adult, we'll wait.
The movie is "Heat," the
Michael Mann classic.
Is it a classic, I guess it's a classic.
Features a fiery and
subdued De Niro crook,
facing off a boisterous, overt Pacino.
It's these two guys
doing what they do best.
And who wins in the end?
Pacino?
I think, right?
It was a long movie.
Both fellows are all-time legends,
but this round goes to the cop
who helped bring down the toughest robbers
in Southern California,
since those surfing ex-presidents,
Mr. Al Pacino.
(bell dinging)
- I work hard for this.
- Wild card round: versatility.
We both know these fellas
can go the mobster route,
like in "The Irishman," which again,
is where this shirt is from.
I hope you're enjoying the French tuck.
- That doesn't help.
- They can take care of that kinda thing.
They can paint houses, kill you,
and bury your body in Jersey.
De Niro's played a mobster 11 times,
and that's not even counting
when he was just a criminal,
in flicks like "Ronin" or "Jackie Brown."
Pacino's been up to no
good in nine movies.
So, while these may be
their most well-known roles,
what else you got?
If you think Al was good as a mobster,
wait until you see him play Satan.
He's everything you'd want as John Milton,
and if you're playing the Devil,
we want a loud, pompous,
over-the-top speech,
and boy, did we get it.
- You know what scares me, John?
I leave the case, she gets better,
and then I hate her for it.
- Pacino was also magnificent
as Sonny in "Dog Day Afternoon,"
Ricky Roma in "Glengarry Glen Ross,"
he tried really hard in "Jack and Jill."
Again, that's an all-time bad movie,
but watching Pacino give
it everything he has
is truly inspiring,
and you feel a little sorry for him.
- Al Pacino, Al Al Pacino,
Al Pacino (giggling).
- Then we come to Mr. De Niro.
Pacino's done a few comedies.
De Niro has crafted an entire
second career out of them.
Let's go all the way
back to "Midnight Run,"
which earned him one of
his Oscar nominations,
and add in the "Analyze This" films
and the "Meet the Parents".
Like most comedy franchises,
they went back to the
well a little too often,
but it was Robert De Niro
that sold those films
as much as any of the more
traditional funny people,
like Billy Crystal or Ben Stiller.
And I can say this with all confidence,
his comedies are better
than "Jack and Jill."
Robert De Niro's worst comedy
is still way better than "Jack and Jill."
I've seem gum on sidewalks
that I'd rather chew than
watch that movie again.
- Oh.
- It's outside of the world of comedy
where De Niro seals the win in this round.
He played the legendary monster
in "Mary Shelley's Frankenstein."
Then, he can go play nice, sweet,
retiree Ben in "The Intern."
And the lengths he will go to for a role
include massive weight gains.
60 pounds for "Raging Bull,"
and another 30 pounds to play
Al Capone in "The Untouchables."
But come on, really, how
hard is it to put on weight?
You have a few extra
pancakes in the morning,
take an extra milkshake
into the shower with you.
We all do that.
But he also lost 29 pounds
to play Travis Bickle,
and he got in like scary, shredded shape
to play Max Cady in "Cape Fear."
Martin Scorsese, great
filmmaker and personal trainer?
His ace client, Robert De Niro
gets the win.
(bell dinging)
- You.
You got a gift, my friend.
- So, here we are, at the end
of this game, all tied up.
This is when you want
your most clutch player to shine through.
Sadly, you just got me.
And between Al Pacino and Robert De Niro,
my pick for the best is...
Fun sidebar time.
Simpletons like me like
to invent a rivalry
for these two fellows,
but the reality is, they're good buddies
who have a tremendous amount
of respect for each other.
However, there have been
a few roles over the years
that could've gone to either.
So Robert De Niro was considered
for the role of Michael Corleone.
That role went to Al Pacino, forcing Al
to bow out of "The Gang That
Couldn't Shoot Straight,"
so Robert stepped into that role.
Pacino was considered for "Taxi Driver,"
before De Niro landed the part.
And Robert De Niro turned down the role
of Coach D'Amato in "Any Given
Sunday," enter Al Pacino.
You see kids?
In life, the inches we
need are all around us.
- Because, that's what livin' is.
- I'm goin' with Robert De Niro
for the win.
(bell dinging)
Why?
Because it's Wednesday,
and that's how I felt when
I woke up this morning.
- This is such a crock of shit.
- 'Cause figure it this way,
better to be king for a night
than a schmuck for a lifetime.
(crowd cheering)
- Could've gone either way,
but it's not lost on me
that he is the lead in "The Irishman,"
and he still carries a film
in a way that few have
ever been able to do.
He can also play comedies, multiple ways,
and dare I say, his range
feels a little broader
as we get towards our senior years.
But that's just my opinion,
now it's your turn.
Comment below and tell us
who the better all-time
great is in your peepers.
Is it Pacino, is it De Niro?
Or does Joe Pesci win,
in a write-in ballot?
- Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
- Thanks for watching, I'm Mark Ellis,
and yes, I was talking to you.
No one else here?
Must've been talking to you.
It's a horrible Travis Bickle,
and that's how I'm walking out.
Thanks, I'll practice.
(upbeat music)